sooner or later the humans are going to  find us up here he should have known  this day was coming  are we supposed to follow our king and  remain silent disease  we need to go to birth now we've been  hiding here too long let's go to our  rightful home if we were on earth we  would have a glorious planet to live on  thrive you're talking about the Train  door brother you're talking about  freezin  you're blind to his intention right or  wrong if dangerous what I'm talking  about is freedom freedom for all in  humans are you going to use your voice  to kill your only brother  [Music]  [Music]  we will not let anyone for anything  soften we will create our destiny  nothing can keep up with being quick  you  you